地区と徳育のお話を伺ったので次は体育に
ついてお願いし
ます体育とスポーツは違う目的が違うん
ですよそれなのに今体育と称してスポーツ
だけやっとうでしょあれは文部将の責任や
ねでどうしてそんな風になったかと言うと
リベラルがうるさいからしいてはいかん
しかないと体育じゃないよよスクールで
投稿拒否を直したあれは何をやったかと
言うと体育と徳育をやったんですそうし
たらば投稿拒否が治ったよう考えてもらわ
んと学校が地区延長になっちまってそれも
本当の地区じゃないでしょ物を覚えれば
ええというわけのわからんカスみたいな
地区やねでそれをのOB卒業した人間偏差
仲裁が偉い人になるもんでもうますます
そうなっちまうねもは覚えたえんやとそれ
がチクなんだということになっちまって察
済は大体において体育が苦手でしょ実際の
行動できない人が多いから文部省の役人で
も体育をろかにするわな体育とは何かを
考えようともしてないよ
ね体育の目的は正しい行動をするこれには
どうしたらいいかつまり正しい行動をする
能力をつけようこれが体育ですですから
修行修行に納める集と行行の方が2つある
でしょ職業の行もう1つは行う行うの方が
体育職業の業こちらの方がスポーツです
ですから体育行うという字はね変化という
意味なんですよだから変化の仕方を覚える
自分の進歩の仕方を覚える体育をやったら
ば何をやってもうまくやれるようになる
これが体育の目的ですよね力がかかるもの
であろうとえ細かいテクニックがいるもの
であろうとえ事を書にしても何でもうまく
やれるそのために体育をやるでうまく
やれるということは正しい精神を作るこれ
は一致するからスポーツは野球なら野球5
職業の業これは具体的な行動を示すから5
っていうわね野球なら野球バスケなら
バスケそういう風にそのもののテクニック
を上げるのがスポーツだから目的は試合に
勝つことになっちゃうえこれがスポーツ
ですですからスポーツをやってもスポーツ
にだって体育的要素は必ずあるから少しは
体育の結果も出せるんだけど体育だけに的
を絞ったものに比べるとやっぱり結果は
ダメなんですわスポーツはねだからまず
体育をしっかりやらせないとイギリスの
パブリックスクー高校やね午後みんな体育
だそれぐらい重要ししとるイギリスの真似
をしたがる日本がどうしてそいつを
取り入れるのかねこういうとこがおかしい
んですわだから自分の苦手なものは排除
しようとする検察修正やね体育はちゃんと
やる今のあの日本の経済がダメになる競争
力がダメになるこれは一生懸命働かん働か
ないからでしょ正しく働かない正しく開発
しない粘りがないこういうものはみんな
体育で作れるんですよねから体育をおろか
にした結果が今日本をダウンさせてる
スポーツだと具体的に何をやるのか想像
できるんですけど体育っていうのは具体的
な話だと何をするんですか体育的な
スポーツがあるんですよ例えばヨット
なんかそうやねうちはウインドサーフィン
とヨットを使うからあれ体育的なスポーツ
なんですともかく頑張らんといかんへばっ
てはいかん1つはこう命がけということが
あるでしょあの人間水に落ちたら死ぬんだ
から落ちないようにせてか生命力がいるわ
ねでその生命力が元になってたくさんの
現象を頑張るにしてもここ1番なんてのが
そうやねここ1番頑張れる今の子見て
ごらんここ1番がダメになるからここ
頑張りゃ乗り切れるのにというとこがダメ
あのウンドサーフなんか走がしてもひっと
風が吹いてきてそこが頑張ればスピードが
つくのにとか言って話しちゃうんよね粘り
がない頑張りが効かでそういうその非常に
有用な性格を作り上げるこれが体育ですよ
ある程度命がけになるものこれこういう
スポーツはみんな体育の効果があるんです
よね死ぬ前として頑張るんだから自分で
考えてこらそういうスポーツはいっぱい
あるからウィンドサーフィンとかっていう
スポーツがうくなったとは言えないんです
かあウンドサーフィンとかあれもうまく
なるよもちろんそれスポーツやからね
繰り返しとればうまくなっちゃうだけど
この前あれん時で説明したやろああいう
やり方あれは体育のやり方な何を養うん
だった集中力集中力ね集中力を持って
スポーツをやってくら非常にうまくできる
んや同じ時間かけてもねこれが体育な剣玉
は1つだって体育をすることができるで
あいつを普通教えるのはただ繰り返し
繰り返しやってそのうちに技術ができて
うくなるというそういう方法を取るじゃ
ないもったいないんや下手くそなうちに
集中力を養練習ができるんだけど学校で
行ってる体育はもうどれもスポーツ寄りに
なってるしいたらいかんていうんやからね
しごくのはけしからんというあのバカな
リベラルどもが守のが体育じゃないそう
いう時でもくびり果てても頑張るとか
そいつを悪いことだと言い出したらも手に
をええんよ
ね体育の定義って何なんですか正しい行動
のトレーニングだ正しい行動はなんつった
義だろ体育をやったら正しくやったら義を
行うことになる義を行うと得意ができる
やろ公然の木を養えるからさその2つで
持ってうちは投拒否を直したい体育が足り
ないとどういう風になってしまうんですか
ああいう投稿拒否の子供飛行の子供みたい
になっちまう頑張れないわがままあの子
たちの特徴はわがままだよそいつをなんか
逆に褒めるような感じのことをやるわね
学校行けんだったら来なくてもいいやと
行けるようになったらいらっしゃいなる
わけないじゃん許してもらえるんやったら
この野郎来なかったら卒業させんぞ言っ
たらもう嫌でも嫌でもなんとか来るわね
そいつを来なくても卒業させてあげます
言ったら俺いかんよね行きたくない怖いん
やけど非常に弱いあの子たちねもうなんて
も怖くてしょうがないんだ我々は喜んで
学校行ったやろ面白いから我々が喜んで
いくようなところが怖くていけないまと
おかしいと思わんとね嫌なことを集中して
やる能力っていうのはタレ目につくって
いうことです嫌なことだからやらんで
いいっていうのが今のあれじゃん体育の
時間見ておらん炭の方に子供が大勢
座り込んで眺めとるわさ体育嫌だからやら
んでええんやあんなことしとったらねそれ
はわがままになるわさ強くならんわさ強く
ならんとだめ特に男は
ねと校長の体育のお話でよくバランス感覚
とかがお話出てくると思うんですけどこれ
についても伺いたいですあれ言ってないか
な暗証系という言葉があるんだ安定の案し
は詳しい今はうやうやしい刑は尊敬の系
これもうやうやしいよね暗証教系っていう
のはね授OKAYの
小額に出てくるんだでこれの意味が学者は
分からんからいかんのやこれはね進歩の
法則ないで案は安定
安定すると一生懸命やれるんだ一生懸命
ってのは正しく強くやなほとんどの場合
一生懸命やると進歩すだから進歩するため
には安定せんといかんねでもう1つは進歩
しよう意思やねこれが出らんといかんね
意思を出すためには系今日はね
うやうやしい
けど自分に対してうやうやしいんや結局
自分の能力を正しく知ってるこれがうう
深夜で思い上がったらだめなんだ暗証系の
安定の部分についてもっと伺いたいですだ
から子供は安定せんといかんこれは肉体的
と精神的と両方精神的に不安定やと進歩し
ないねそんなも頑張ることなんてできない
だから精神的に安定しないといけないから
もう1つは肉体的に安定行動だからね安定
て行動せんといかで行動すると今度は動的
安定がいるんよね動いとる時に安定して
動いとらんといかこれこれを練習しとこう
やないかそしたらどんどん進歩するんだ
からこれウィンドサーフィンはあんなええ
ものないよもうバランスロスポーツやもん
でねあいつをやっとけば構造面の肉体的な
安定はうまくなるちゃんとできるように
なるでもう1つの精神的な安定は男の仕事
な父親が弱いといざという時に自分は助け
てもらえない強いやつしか助けれんからね
だから不安なんだ人間も動物だからね敵
から襲われた時にやばいわけそん時に親が
バンとこう正面に立って助けてくれれば
そのためには父親が強くなていただから
父親が弱いとまかかで
あるいは父親が全くいない母子家庭やね
そういうとこの子供が飛行になったり投
拒否になったりするんやそいつを親の死刑
が悪いからなんつって言い出すわけやね
バカどもそうやない大体リベラルが離婚
さしとるわけやろリベラルという哲学で
あればこんな離婚した方がええということ
になっちゃうからねそういうねリベラルが
とかく悪いことするその場をよくするため
に戦術的にいいだけど戦略的にはまずい
反対のことやっとるんだだからリベラル
教育はみんなおかしくなっちゃうやろ
えっとね私の言うことは正しいこと
ばっかりだだから今からまだ続くから
えー正しい
人生死ぬ時に満足の行く人生それを送り
たけれ
ばチャンネル登録して
ずっと聞いてくれ